[Applause]
welcome to the latest episode of just
getting started
as you know i started this podcast a few
months ago
in the middle of the height of the
pandemic to try and give everybody an
idea
of maybe uh starting on your
your life plan or restarting your life
plan to
do whatever you need to do to maybe um
figure things out that you don't think
you have the ability to figure things
out through the origin stories of my
guests that i couldn't be more pleased
to have on this episode of just getting
started
an emmy award winner a screen actors
guild award winner
a golden globe award winner many times
over but for the first time an author
holding her book up right here this it's
called sunshine girl
in unexpected life julianna margulies
right here on just getting started how
you doing juliana
i'm good thank you for having me thanks
for being on here i
i i am uh thrilled to be chatting with
you
i i i know i wrote a book back in 2007
and um no matter what i've done since
then anybody said hey i've read your
book
it means so much it's so personal why
did you decide to
uh write a book and write this memoir
sunshine
girl um yeah
it is amazing now that it's out in the
world to to be
hearing the responses from it it's just
a
a really fascinating journey um i
decided to write the book
really um after i finished seven years
on the good wife um i had gotten
incredibly ill
my last day of shooting right when i got
home
and that sort of quashed all the plans i
had
for being um i wanted to be really uh
you know
sort of dive into the world of what
would it be like not to
have to wake up at six in the morning
and go to work and learn
14 pages of dialogue and work non-stop
and i was really excited about
um sort of a a calm life ahead of me
and instead i got the chicken pox and i
was held up in bed
for three weeks and in a way i look at
it now and see
what an incredible gift it was because
it gave me the time
to start writing things down
to i had to shed alicia's skin
when you are in someone else's shoes for
seven years always thinking like them
and wondering how they would react to
something over how you would react to
something
it made me realize that i hadn't quite
examined my own life enough
and alicia florek the character i played
on the good wife had
such a hold on me because it was also at
a time in my life
it started so soon after i'd had
my kid and gotten married and started
this new life
that i was so happy to welcome
um into my journey forward and then all
of a sudden it was just plate spinning
you know
there was no time for anything and um i
thought wow this is
this is a time to sort of
dig down deep let go of alicia and
figure out what it is
i want to do and how i want to comport
the next
phase of my life and in doing so
i realized that i hadn't examined my own
life enough
and so i started to unpeel the layers
and as you know you know once
you you start writing a book and i mean
it's had so many iterations right you
start
um i i had written nine chapters when i
was sick and
and then of course the scabs went away
and the chickenpox went away and i got
better
and i had um i had submitted the nine
chapters to my agent and she said you
know i actually really this is
you had a fascinating childhood i think
you have a book here
and but of course the second i got
better job acting jobs started coming in
so it was
one of those painful processes where i
would be so ready
to write and then i'd realize that you
know i was doing a
mini series called the hot zone where i
was having to learn scientific dialogue
and i thought
what did i get myself into i can't
learn these lines and write a book and
so i finally figured out a balance
between it all
but in doing so it took me four years
and in those four years the book went
through many iterations
and ultimately i stripped everything
down and ended up with this sort of very
raw
truthful honest um
view of my life and and how i got to
where
the subtitle of the book which is an
unexpected life
is really the truth in i never
ever expected my life to be this
wonderful
um so so that sort of was the journey in
and um the peeling of the layers back to
discover
who i was as a child who i was while i
was working while i was in relationships
and where i got to now so i guess it's a
good thing you didn't get chickenpox as
a kid
exactly i actually thought i was immune
but you know when we were little
rich i think we're around the same age
but yeah my kid
my kid and your kids all have chickenpox
vaccines
right when i would when we were kids our
moms would put us in rooms
you know with other other kids who had
chickenpox it actually sounds a little
medieval now doesn't it
went sick um but
i never got them so i thought i was
immune to chickenpox
so i guess i should ask you so
were you able to finish your book
because you got mononucleosis or like
i mean like i think it's sort of it's
sort of
um wow yeah it was the only way i was
going to slow down and stop
you know it really was the gift of time
and i think we've all learned this
through the pandemic right
the gift of time to just slow down and
take a breath
and really examine
how you want your life to be i think i
think i hope
many people have learned through this
pandemic in the lockdown
you know to value our time and and to
not get caught up in that
that whirlwind of what we call life
but is it truly living your truest life
no i i feel that because you know
you know you know my wife as well um and
we've been talking about it now that we
seem to be thank goodness on the back
end of this pandemic
did we do enough with our time down
like now that we are getting back into
the normal did we do enough of what
you've just talked about the evaluation
of yourself you know in the town we we
and we're wondering if we actually did
enough
to do that's what you're talking about
yeah because
didn't it feel i mean for me some days
my husband and i would say at the end of
the day my god it's groundhog day
yeah you know because tomorrow's gonna
start up and that and we don't see our
friends and we don't see our family we
only see the three of us when we're
you know and for me i was finishing a
book and and also
um um voicing a documentary
for pbs about these unsung women heroes
and so
my day just started and get the kid
online for school and run and do the
grocery shopping and make sure there's
lunch you know
all the things and then write two
chapters and edit and
and do the laundry and clean the house
it just became sort of this
day of chores and um then on the
weekends
we would try and just not do anything
and play games and i taught my kid how
to play poker and
you know i tried to make fun for him
because he's an only child and i felt
terrible that he was stuck with
two parents right helicoptering around
him
um watching his every move and i wanted
there to be some sort of joy
but one of the things we did that really
i'm really grateful for my husband's
always been
someone who meditates and i never have i
was a yogi i did a lot of yoga but
you know i had gotten so injured from it
that i had stopped doing yoga and my
thing was going out for these six mile
runs every day and that was sort of my
meditation
but then we all decided
to start meditating together and our new
year's resolution
um we don't make them for ourselves we
make them for each other what would you
like
that person to to be able to because i
always feel like when you
make a new year's resolution and break
it then you just feel worse
yeah right month later so we sat around
the table and said
um what is your wish for that person
and all three of us had the exact same
wish for each other which was
to keep meditation as a part of our
daily lives even when we get back into
the crazy
um i can't say we've i feel like i've
failed miserably
right but i do do it as often as i can
so uh let's get into your origin story
which uh you know
obviously i'll keep holding up your book
i love the picture on the cover too
sunshine girl and unexpected life how
did you get started
how did you get started on your career
and and my life
well so i had a very um chaotic
childhood
of divorced parents um which isn't
wasn't isn't so odd
being a child of the 70s you know i mean
most
uh marriages ended in divorce at that
point
um but i am the daughter of
two soul seekers and
in my childhood
both my parents a little bit before i
was born i was sort of a happy accident
i suppose one could say
i don't know if they would have said it
at the time but their marriage was
pretty much over
the day when i when they found out i was
my mother was pregnant with me
um and they divorced when i was about
one and my father moved to paris
to um he was in advertising a copywriter
and he was
um asked to take this job in paris so we
moved
about a year later so there was a lot of
moving around it was paris for two years
london for three years then we all moved
back to
new york where we lived in the suburbs
my dad lived in new york city
and then my mother decided to move me
and my sister
um my i'm the youngest of three girls my
eldest sister
was studying ballet the school of
american ballet
she decided she couldn't live with my
mother anymore at the age of 12.
my mother is sort of the central
character in my book
she's incredibly eccentric and
narcissistic
but in a strange
when i say that it sounds really awful
but
the truth is my mom is one of the most
fantastic people i've ever met
she's incredibly complex incredibly
difficult
but magnificent at the same time and
the job i found the hardest to write
about in the book
was to balance out the love that she
gave
her children because there was true
beautiful love there
and the crazy that she made us go
through because
her needs came first so sort of this up
and down
um life i had and my mother who
had a string of boyfriends it was like a
revolving door so you know when you when
you're a child you get
attached to one and then the next one
leaves and then
you get attached to the next or you
don't get attached at all because you
know how it's going to end
um i was always taking in
the temperature of the room what mood
was my mother in and that's the moniker
the reason the book is called sunshine
girl
is because that was my mother's nickname
for me as a child
and as beautiful as that sounds and i
know it does and i did wear it
as a badge of honor for many many years
um i i felt
beholden to anyone sitting in the room
to make them feel happy
so i didn't complain and i didn't um i i
hid
my true feelings often because i wanted
to be the one
that was easy since my mother was so
difficult my middle sister was moody and
my eldest sister was
doing ballet far away from us living
with my father it just was a lot of
uncertainty and i knew that with
with a smile and a sunshiny
disposition i could actually
change the mood in the room
the problem with that is as i got older
that name
and that title was embedded in my psyche
and so then when i went out into the
world
um i had a hard time drawing boundaries
i had a hard time saying no this doesn't
feel right i don't like this i like this
i i just was a people pleaser i just
wanted everyone to be happy
regardless of how i felt and i brought
that into
my my own romantic relationships which
is never
never a very good recipe for a
successful relationship
if you're never saying how you really
feel so
um because i was moving from different
countries and we
went back to england and was pulled away
from my father then i came back to
america but we ended up in new hampshire
which was like
being in a foreign country in and of
itself
for a girl who came straight from london
um i guess i was always putting on
someone else's shoes
trying out someone else's accent taking
you know
looking around the classroom to see how
those kids dressed and i was always
playing
a character i was never playing myself
so i really as i was writing the book
and i write about this in one of the
chapters what else could i have done
but act that that was i had the perfect
backdrop in my childhood to become an
actor because
it wasn't until i got to college and i
never
thought about being an actor i actually
thought i was going to be a
lawyer or something with gravitas my my
grandmother was one of the first women
to graduate
from nyu law school in 1924 and i always
wanted to follow in her footsteps i
thought that that was a noble profession
um and when i got to college my freshman
year i was cast in a play
and that opening night of this david ray
play called in the boom boom room
just it's it was one of those lightning
bolt
moments the curtain comes up the lights
the audience and i had this outer body
experience which was
this is where i'm meant to be i'm
finally home
because i hadn't really had a home home
in a for most of my life to be honest
with you
and i felt so at home on the stage
and also i was able to express myself
through these characters so i could be
angry and ugly and mean and
throughout through through other
people's writing right so i didn't have
to take
responsibility as julianna i could play
a mean crazy drunk
and get my yayas out on stage
and it became sort of my safe place and
so
um that's how i realized i was
gonna act did it come easy to you or did
you have a moment where
you had a fight for something or you
were
like how did you how did you climb well
i
i really i got lucky really early i mean
i i think
oh god um i had a five year plan
um my five-year plan was
if i wasn't making a living acting if i
couldn't
pay my rent put food on the table and
have
health insurance by the time i was 25
i would go back to school i'd be young
enough that i could still go back to
graduate school and be
a lawyer or a psychologist or whatever
it was
so i always felt very confident
when i went into these auditions because
i had a
backup plan if it didn't work out you
know
um and i also thought if i haven't made
it by then maybe
that's just the world telling me i'm not
good enough
and i got an agent right out of college
and
and six months after waitressing
i got my first movie and i got a sad
card
um and it's so funny that the the
naivete that goes along with your first
job as an actor when you get that sad
card and
you know you get a paycheck for acting
not that it was much but
you think i'm never gonna have to
waitress or bartend or check codes again
like
this will never happen again and sure
enough
you know six months later i was behind
the bar
i'm pouring gin and tonics um but i was
on my way
because i had a sad card casting
director started to know me
and i had a movie under my belt and so
for me really i got lucky
i would say pretty much
you know a year out of college i was
making my living acting
i mean doing regional theater making 230
dollars
a week but i was pay i i had my equity
card i got my equity card from yale rep
when
that was the first equity play i did so
i had
health insurance and um and i could pay
my rent and it was meager but
that's how i started and what helped me
a lot too was commercials
i did um i think three
national commercials that kept me afloat
and every time i kept thinking i'd have
to go back to bartending or
waiting on tables i would get a residual
check that would cover that month
you know what what were the commercials
oh my god well my first
big commercial um where it's such a
funny story because i was furious
at my agents because they sent me in on
this ethan allen furniture commercial
and it was me and
25 seven foot tall blonde no
nordic looking models sitting in the
waiting room and i was
furious because i was embarrassed i'm
5'7 i'm dark i'm jewish
like what was i doing in this waiting
room and um
i caught i remember remember phone but
there was no there was no
cell phone back then i called my
commercial agent from the street from
the phone booth and i was like don't do
that to me it's mortifying
i'm not a model i'm not seven feet tall
and it's just mortifying and they said
well you got it
and i said i got i got the job
how did i get the job they said you were
the only one who looked real
and you knew how to furniture
so hey this kind of works
that marshall ran for a year nationally
and i made more money off that i could
not believe how much money i was made
and i never had to speak i just had to
move me and the guy playing my husband
with a little dog like we just had to
move furniture around i didn't even
say a line and then the next commercial
i got was mcdonald's commercial
and actually um paris barkley cast me in
that
um director yeah um he's head of the
director's guild at this point um but a
wonderful guy and he directed er and he
directed the good wife so so he and i go
way back to mcdonald's and it was
um they wanted a black person
a very very white person and then an
in-between person
and no one in those days seemed to think
that i was white
i was always like is she latino is she
part black what what is she but because
i guess with the curly hair and
i don't know i got cast in the middle of
these
um two people and we had to eat hot
wings
and um which is quite funny because we
all got these
broke out in these terrible bumps all
over our mouths and then they said
actually don't
try not to let it touch your lips
because there's so much chemic we have
chemicals on them
to make them look good and we had spit
buckets i mean it's a very
very glamorous job that i have um
but that was a national commercial and
then i did another mcdonald's for some
reason mcdonald's
liked me and i don't even i at that time
i was completely vegetarian so
um uh yeah mcdonald's and ethan allen
saved me
[Music]
[Applause]
this episode of just getting started is
sponsored by home
made a podcast from rocket mortgage
about the meaning of home and what it
can teach us about ourselves and others
the show is really enjoyable these are
provocative
poignant even hilarious stories that
explore the diversity of home in america
and the fundamental need for shelter and
belonging that unites us all
michael wood lewis moved to this great
neighborhood hoping to become friends
with his new neighbors but that didn't
exactly happen until
he built his own social network to make
friends all across vermont
in another episode shaheen pasha
searches for someone known to her
immigrant family only as
the landlady who 30 years earlier had
rescued them from homelessness when they
arrived from pakistan
but the search takes shaheen deep into
possibly
unfriendly territory the stories from
home
made will inspire you as much as they
did me so
search for home made anywhere you listen
to podcasts that's two words
you can tell throughout this
conversation home
and m-a-d-e home and made my thanks to
home
made for their support on this podcast
[Applause]
how did you wind up on er er came um
i was out in l.a i got flown out there
to visit
a boyfriend who i thought i'd get to
live with that didn't work out so well
um and i was in la
living in a rented room i found to rent
in laurel canyon
and i had a good agent at that point a
pretty good agent
um but i wasn't having a very good time
out there
in new york casting directors knew me i
was sort of the regional theater girl i
had done a couple little independent
things and i had done homicide life on
the street the year before which was a
great
tom fontana barry levinson um actually
ned beatty my all my scenes were with
ned beatty i played a violinist and he
played the cello
anyway um
so i was known in new york i mean no
when i say that by casting directors who
would call me officer in l.a the casting
directors didn't seem that thrilled
to get to know me and i just felt like i
was having a hard time breaking in
and i decided to move back to new york i
was like you know what i'm
i need a season to move forward my
family was back here so
i went i needed to make some money to
get the plane fare home
and i went on an audition um
for this show called er and uh
i i had two other auditions it was pilot
season i don't know if pilot season
exists anymore with streaming and
whatnot but
um january and february is pilot season
and that's when you go out on all your
auditions for television shows that are
coming and so i went and i and i
had two auditions after the er edition
and it was to be it was to play a series
um not a series regular but
could become a series regular she would
be a recurring and it would be the
love interest for the doug ross
character who at the time no one knew
you know george clooney i mean a few
people might have but he wasn't george
clooney then
um the george clooney we know today
anyway um i went in and there the place
was packed with actors
and the wait was going on and on and i
was gonna miss my other two auditions
because it went on for two hours and i
had that new york terrible attitude
i was like you know what [ __ ] it oh can
i say that honestly
um please please say it i just [ __ ] it
i'm out of here
uh two hours like i understand 30
minutes 40 minutes but two hours is
ridiculous and so i got up to leave just
as
the casting director john levy was
coming out and he said called my name
so when i went in to audition for this
part that was supposed to be a doctor
who was a bit flirty
um and i read the whole scene
just pissed off turfs and uninterested
in being there
and i and i literally i just and there's
mike michael creighton was sitting there
steven spielberg
john wells the director rod holcomb and
i got up and left and
and um john levy came running after me
and he goes so you're not right for that
part and i went you think
because i was just i was just done
and he goes but you're really right for
this nurse her name is carol hathaway
and she dies in the pilot would you
uh read for her and he hands me slides
which for your listeners if they don't
know just means the dialogue
and i was so oh my god
i was such a new york theater snob i
said
you know i actually prepare for
auditions i don't do cold readings
oh [ __ ] and john
he just chuckled and he said okay so go
prepare
and he brought me into a you know let me
i think i was sitting in a stairwell of
a
fire exit and he and i said
and he goes just knock when you're ready
and so i
read these lines for hathaway and i
knocked and i went in
and i was just furious and i didn't care
i didn't want to ever see these people
again i thought okay i get it spielberg
and i and i should have impressed him
and i know
i was about to say one of them's steven
spielberg i know i mean
i know i just was i know they made you
wait but holy i mean
wow no i think i i think i was
embarrassed and i don't know
my pride had been wounded you know
anyway i went home
and um my agent called she goes you got
the part and i didn't know i said which
part because i had two other auditions
and she said er and i said what the
nurse
and she said yeah yeah and i said oh
okay great and i
i thought well she dies right she dies
in the pilot and she goes well she does
die in the pilot
um but they really want you to do the
part they think you're perfect for it
and i said well okay
how much is it going to pay because i
just wanted enough money to get back to
new york i thought i'll go do this pilot
and then i can fly home and i'll never
forget
because i'd never heard this she said
well they're gonna pay you twenty
thousand dollars i know it's not much
i dropped the phone i started jumping up
and down suddenly
i loved l.a yeah i loved everything
about
the process i had just been through i
was like wait what
and uh and i went and did the pilot and
had
for three weeks we shot that pilot and i
think in a two-hour pilot
maybe maybe they shot for a month in a
two-hour pilot i have
seven minutes of screen time but
what happened was the way they shot my
death my character od in the pilot and
comes in on a gurney
od and that was really the beginning of
steadicam stuff like i always said that
the steadicam on er was really a seventh
character on that show
but the way that rod holcomb shot it he
shot
my sort of overdose through george
clooney's eyes
and through the eyes of sherry and noah
and
anthony edwards and eric because they
were all around that
gurney when i come in and you just see
their
they're stricken but you really see
george clooney's character doug ross is
just
because they had had a history and she
so apparently the i'm back in new york
i'm about to take another job and george
clooney called me and said
i don't know a lot but i get the feeling
they want to keep you alive don't take
another job
get out of here he killed you he called
you
he's the one who called you and said he
called me
i don't know you know he and i have
never discussed
um why he was so kind
to throw me that incredible bone that
changed my career
um i think the girl
who had played his love interest
the part i had messed up he didn't get
along with her
um it wasn't a happy um
coupling on the pilot i is my i
that was the feeling i was getting and i
think
um you know like the other like
the other five main characters of that
show i threw lines away that some people
might have made
a meal out of because that was what that
show was you didn't make
a meal out of these lines you said your
lines and you moved on because there was
another
you know critically injured person in
the next room
so you never made meals out of anything
and um
anyway i turned the other job down and
waited
and a week later they called and flew me
out to la and
and i became a senior regular the rest
is history
the rest is history i know i it's just
and it's amazing i do want to in our
remaining time i want to hit on a couple
other aspects of your career but
it just strikes me that you never
know right you never know or may or did
it help that you were pissed that they
made you wait and that you
you know you know what i mean like that
you didn't get tight you didn't care so
much that you needed it even though you
needed the money to get back east
exactly it's interesting because the
original title of my book
was called a left instead of a right you
never know because that's something my
grandfather always used to say to me
when i was little
like you know if you take a left instead
of a right you might bump into the guy
you're going to marry
that's how he that's how he met my
grandmother he happened to pick up his
sister at
law school that day my grandmother and
my great-aunt marley were both at nyu
and out came my grandmother and it was
like he was in love
and so i always used to say you know you
never know if you make a left instead of
a right your whole day can change
or a right instead of a left whatever
and and so i like that idea because with
er
if i hadn't been angry and if i hadn't
done that audition with a tur snide
attitude
i don't think i would have gotten her
and who knows
how i how that day was going for the
casting director and for you know
maybe someone maybe john wells was late
getting to the
you don't know why the casting session
started late or why
you know we were all waiting or why my
time slot was my time slot so it's like
just a confluence of events that leads
you to the life you lead
i love that idea and i love um
i love that which is when i get to the
end of my book i talk about
i'm sorry the life that i have
i happened to have
gone to a dinner party i wasn't gonna go
to because i was about to start a
broadway show i was
working on the sopranos i didn't have
time and i
i went for a quick drink thinking to
leave
and i met my husband we haven't been
apart since that party
no kidding and i i just think like
things like that make me
so i get so i get a little clumped
because you think
a million times i said to myself i can't
i have lines to learn for this play
i'm i'm i'm i'm doing i'm shooting the
sopranos
the next day and and i have a rehearsal
like there's no way and
the friend who invited me the party talk
talked me into just come for one drink
and then leave
and of course i i stayed
i think i was the last person there with
my now husband
and um i went very hungover by the way
to the
rehearsal the next day but we literally
haven't
been apart since and the amount of times
and i talk about this in the book it's
like
we never would have met my husband at
the time was a lawyer
our circles never would have
intermingled
it just wouldn't have happened so what
if i had said no
where would my life be then because now
i i i'm leading a life i've always
dreamed about
with a partner who's in he's my rock
he's
solid and we have this kid and we have
this life and
i just from such chaos to what i have
now
i just think how can that just be
because
and not with some sort of deeper meaning
you know
i love it i do love it about sliding
doors road nuts taken
or or roads that you do take because you
do say yes or
or i i i love that i mean you mentioned
the sopranos juliana that's one of the
uh touchstones i wanted to hit with you
here because you know obviously we just
we just established er and how you got
into it and what that did become
and you know the good wife is something
that uh
you helped create right i mean you know
and and and you'd already already
established that you needed some time
to get out of your character's skin
after being in that skin for a long time
but the sopranos was
i mean you want to talk about when you
joined it i mean that the sopranos was
already
uh as iconic a television show as you
could possibly
get and and uh yeah is that like for you
to step on that
set julie you know those are one of
those phone calls when they said david
chase has written this part
and he wants you to do it and then you
get the sides
no one ever read a whole script at least
not guest stars you know when
um i never i actually never saw an
entire script i only ever saw my sides
um things were in lock lockdown on that
show sure
um and then to read this character named
julianna yes and spelled with two ends
the way i spell mine um
it was i was it was such an incredible
moment i was like
wow um i first of all i
knew michael imperioli um
i knew james gandolfini because we all
started out in new york doing
you know student films and basements for
nyu directors you know so over the years
and in
theater and plays and michael and
perioli had done a play with an
ex-boyfriend of mine so every day
you know i went out afterwards every
night with those guys so
um and i knew edie for years she and i
played um
hasidic jews in a in a boaz yakin film
called the price above rubies so i knew
these people
um and uh and funnily enough
um matt weiner who wrote on the show
had just done the pilot
of mad men and he was a little bit
obsessed with the fact that paul
margulies
is my father because my father wrote
plot plot fizz fizz oh what a relief it
is he wrote the city never sleeps city
bank he wrote i mean
he was a very
my dad was the exact opposite of mad men
though my father
um my father was a vegetarian who didn't
drink or smoke and only wanted to just
read his philosophy books
so that doesn't sound like don draper
until i guess maybe the end when he was
doing yoga or something i don't know
i know i said to my because he would
have to sit through those three martini
lunches sipping his chamomile tea
and eating his you know vegetable plate
while they're all smoking and
you know it was hell for him and matt
weiner actually gave me on the set of
the sopranos
the pilot that no one had seen of mad
men
and said would you show this to your
father please
and let me know what he thinks and my
dad at the time was in the berkshires
and i
drove up one weekend and i said dad we
have to watch this that
one of the writers he's an incredible
writer on the sopranos wants you to see
it
and my father looked at me and he said
juliana
i spent my whole life trying to get out
of those rooms
the last thing i want to do is sit and
watch them
so he never saw one episode
of mad men which um i well now matt will
know i've never told that story
i think i was like no my dad loved it i
i don't remember but
um being on that show you know even even
though
i think i did barely six episodes of the
last season of their
their sixth season um
but it was it was heaven for me i mean
there's also something to be said for
um you know all these actors who were
such new york thespians
and and real uh gritty you know there
was no
there was no diva attitude on that show
and james gandolfini
always treated everyone with such
respect and kindness
um and and michael i just had a ball i
loved it i wished i had had a scene with
edie i never had a scene with her but
do you think i'll ask you do you do you
think um
tony dies in that diner juliana what do
you think
i'm asking you a straight up television
history question to somebody who has
spent
time on that set what do you think do
you think he dies in that time
i personally at the time when i watched
when i watched it i didn't
but maybe that's because i was in denial
and i was so sad the show was ending and
i think a lot of us feel that way
yes you know um because you want it
to continue but then when i hear that
david chase has written a prequel
right he wrote a film that that jimmy
son is is
young um tony and then i think
oh yeah maybe he died
you know why but you know because
there's nowhere else to go with it yeah
i think so too and and i just i remember
by the way the
the anniversary of the final episode
just uh passed
last week actually and that was a time
where
um because the the um
i guess wasn't even a fade to black just
the black
silence lasting so long everybody looked
at me because if we were watching it in
my house they thought i forgot to pay
the bill
for directv and staring at me like what
the hell like it just went out
um but nightmare
oh yeah i'm like don't blink don't look
at me i mean i don't know what the
hell's going on either
but you know in retrospect i think that
long silence definitely means that he
was in the gateway i think to
his life personally i really feel that
way it was a big loss i think for all of
us when
when he when james died um that funeral
i went to that funeral
and i have to say uh that was a really
tragic time
we lost a great one with him he was a
magnet you know there was something
about him
everyone he was like a moth to the flame
we just all
we we ran to him there was something
about him that you just wanted to
be in his orbit um and he also sometimes
could be a little scary but in a good
way
you know it's sort of like larger than
life
um for sure but i felt really
uh blessed that i got to work with him
and and beyond that show it's such an
iconic show
[Music]
[Applause]
do you own or rent your home of course
you do and i bet it can be hard work you
know what's easy
bundling policies with geico geico makes
it easy to bundle your homeowners or
renters insurance along with your auto
policy
it's a good thing too because you
already have so much to do around your
home
go to geico.com get a quote and see how
much you could save
it's geico easy visit geico.com today
that's
geico.com
[Applause]
and then you know your your own iconic
show as well with uh the good wife um
and i'll just give you the floor on what
what you were most proud of about that
that show
juliana and i guess why how that might
inform us about what you said earlier on
that you needed some
time to kind of unwind from
being that character for as long as you
were yeah
i i was really drawn from the moment i
read the pilot um i don't know if in la
you guys
were as glued to the television as new
yorkers were
when elliot spitzer had a press
conference
and his wife um was standing behind him
at that press conference
i was screaming at the television
begging for her to get off that stage
he didn't deserve to have her standing
behind him and i
um i was really taken by it
and then when i read the pilot i thought
oh my god this is
i i need to play her because i need to
know what happens after
what happens in the green room that's
why the kings wrote
the good wife when they saw that
uh press conference they wanted to know
what was said in the green room
like what do you say after that you know
and so this character for me i i'm most
proud i have to say
uh i mean i can't say i you know the
kings wrote
it i i was just their conduit to be able
to
reach an audience and let their lines be
said through me but
what i'm most proud of is at the time
there were no female lead characters on
network television
like that so this was 2009
and dealing with
what elite what alicia deals with a
flandering cheating husband and you find
out
that you have put your career my
character graduated top in her class at
georgetown law
higher than the josh charles character
higher than
her husband and she put her career on
the back burner
well not even the back burner she quit
to raise her kids
and what happened he ends up
just a disgrace and she is
literally swimming to shore to try and
save her life
you know doggy paddle style she was
drowning
and had to go back to law at the age of
42
no one wants to hire a 42 year old woman
um and still take care of her two
children protect them from the horrible
press that's happening about their
father
and somehow maintain her sanity
i cannot tell you how many women
that role resonated with it didn't
necessarily have to be a flandering
husband
but the whole idea that who are we when
we go to college as women and then we
decide on a career and then because we
are
caretakers and have children and stop
our lives
and when i say our lives i mean our
careers to have these children which
if you want to just have the children
and that's your
career that's great but when you have
tried
to fulfill a dream and go to graduate
school and then that dream
you're the one in the marriage that has
to sit back
the amount of women who saw alicia as
a way for them to move forward with
their own careers
and still be a mom we could we can do it
but women know how to juggle
it's not easy there's no such thing as
work-life balance i'm sure susie will
tell you that
that's impossible you know it's just
like it's really hard
um but i also
do believe that if if i you know for me
personally if i don't have my work i'm
not a good parent
if i don't i need to feel fulfilled
intellectually
for myself in order to be the best
parent i can be
and i think so many women feel that way
um
and so what i loved most about the show
was how it resonated
um now this was in the beginning you
know it was called the good wife so we
didn't get a lot of male
viewers at first because of the name of
the show and apparently they tried to
find a million other
titles and it went back to the good wife
and then
about three seasons in i started getting
stopped on the street by men
who would say my my wife's so obsessed
with your show and i didn't want to
watch it because i thought it was all
girly and it's called the good wife and
so
then i started watching it it's such a
good show
yeah and so then i then it you know it
it resonated with men too
um and young young
people who would come up all the time i
still get letters from them saying
i became a lawyer because of your
character so i think what i'm most proud
of
is is that the show really resonated
with human beings who
who want to fulfill a dream for
themselves who want to get out of this
idea of
this is a women can only do one thing
um and and it gave people confidence to
go and
and and follow their dream which i think
so often we we sort of stop ourselves
because we think we well you can't
do both um anyway so i guess that's a
long-winded answer i'm sorry but um
well you know and i guess to to wrap
this conversation up
um what would you tell your younger self
that maybe can inform people who are
watching this
pod or listening to it right now juliana
to to get started on
on something that they put aside or
they've decided that there's no
odds of being successful what what
what would you tell somebody um that uh
you know is going to read your book
hasn't yet read your book what have you
uh that your journey can inform them in
a way
yeah so in in my book and i and i and i
i
i dedicate almost a whole chapter to it
i i discussed
the reason why i turned down 27 million
dollars to stay on er for an extra two
years
um that wasn't the part that was so
interesting to me what was interesting
to me was the journey in how i got there
and the advice i got from my father and
listening to my own heart
um and i would tell you and i spoke
about it at the 2010
uh i was the commencement speaker at my
alma mater sarah lawrence college and i
i said to the students you know
money is a great thing i love making
money
it's a privilege to be able to not worry
about your rent
or the food on your table
but if you do not listen to your own
heart
not all the voice is telling you what to
do if you do not stay true to yourself
you're never going to leave this planet
with money in your pockets
that doesn't go with you your soul and
your heart
is what matters and i think everyone
especially today
i feel bad for young people because
everyone has an opinion right on
social media seems like everyone's a
judge and everyone
can you know comment on
you um i would say
don't listen to others especially people
who
have nothing to do with your life uh
listen to your heart
and go to the person you respect and
admire the most
for your advice don't don't go with the
the herd be your own person and be true
to yourself because
and i and i write about this in one of
the chapters my father had said to me
you know i know a lot of rich unhappy
people
and what if you go and do this for two
years
but you get hit by a bus before the two
years is over
and as your soul is leaving your body
you look down
at yourself and you say what do you say
to yourself you weren't living your
best life you weren't living your
happiest life you were waiting
finding time to get rich there's no time
like the present
and i think if anything we've learned
through this pandemic
is my god you have to listen to your
heart
and you ha and you have to respect
your own thoughts before you do someone
else's
um so that's what i would say other
people may disagree with me
but it's it has always steered me
correctly
and and i think the most important thing
in life is not to have regrets
so try and live your life that way
without thinking oh i'm gonna regret
this
try not to have that it's beautiful and
the
book sunshine girl and unexpected life
by julianna margulies can be gotten
where all books are acquired
uh of all the things that you said that
makes me want to hit a follow-up
question including the fact that your
your dad came up with plop flop fizz
fizz for alka-seltzer
the the one i do want to ask you going
out the door is how
how good it poker is your son oh my god
you know listen when he gets arrested
for card counting when he's 18
everyone can blame me i'll i i
i i you know he's good he um he
he's he's actually quite good um
and and i'm a little a little bit
worried um
and he really enjoys it he loves any
game that has some sort of strategy
he loves he he's a but um and
and i love it and the nice thing is is
that he comes over and now
he plays with all my friends so
clean them out i love it juliana thank
you for doing the pod i really
appreciate it
thanks for having me it was a pleasure
julianna margulie's right here on just
getting started
[Music]
that was a total blast i i love stories
about people who get their big breaks
when they least expect it no
maybe that's honestly maybe that's the
way to go through life i i know that
some people put so much pressure on
themselves
and it's difficult to have the attitude
of you don't care because that's the
least
attractive one would say attitude
or personality traits that anybody wants
to hire anybody would have
um but you know
that story about how she was pissed and
that's how she got you know on the radar
screen of some people
at um at uh
er that they wanted her to read for
another part because of it and then
she got the opportunity and then
got it and then she was so terrific at
it she
got the ultimate opportunity the
game-changing life-changing opportunity
but also
the story about her getting her first
commercial where as she put it she was
in a room filled with seven
foot tall blonde women you know
teutonic goddesses and she thought she'd
have no opportunity no shot and
she got the job because of who she is
you know that uh in the same way i think
it was rob lowe a couple of weeks ago
saying that you have your fingerprint
that's what she he said that
um well that was that was no that was
kelsey grammer last week
saying that uh uh nicholas colosanto the
actor who played
coach told him this is your fingerprint
this is who you are don't let anybody
mess with that
and here we have another story kind of
telling you the same thing that you are
who you
are and belief in yourself that your
personality and your essence is the
differentiator
always tell that to people when they're
asking how do you break into
broadcasting and i said be yourself
that you're your own walking fingerprint
and that's true
i mean if you're going to try and put on
a voice or heirs and not be yourself
then you're you won't succeed in the
television
sports tv business that's for sure i
mean you do hear some guys
you know who who in you know i guess
talking hairdos is the phrase that a lot
of people use
uh though those folks don't have staying
power the most successful people i ever
met in
sports television berman chris berman
stuart scott dan patrick keith olbermann
linda cone just five off the top my head
from my sports center days michael irvin
uh steve mariucci everybody who i work
with at nfl network on the air
they are exactly who they are off the
air is the one that you see
on the air dion he's exactly the same
person
when he doesn't have a camera on him as
when he does and
i i i've always taken that
as a life lesson and then just hearing
juliana margulies tell the story about
how she got her first commercial and how
she got
er and then what her father told her
about
not taking a job just for the money i
understand that that might not be
relatable for a lot of people
certainly in this day and age it's the
same concept of just being true to
yourself and
this whole book is about that and i
suggest everybody go get it
certainly since she'll tell some uh even
bigger and greater stories than the ones
that she told from her career right here
on this edition of just getting started
so do us a favor
uh for all of us here just getting
started subscribe if this is your first
one if you know a friend a fan of
julianna margulies that
would like it suggest it subscribe and
give us a nice rating give us a five
star rating we always appreciate that
leave a comment
um i i always
am um interested in feedback and what
people think of what people would like
to hear or guess you want to hear
put it up there i'll check it out so
that's it for this episode of just
getting started we appreciate you
taking this one in we'll see you next
time
you